how did hobo jack from american pickers
get his nickname especially since he
seems to own most of a town and what
about those rumors he died keep watching
to find out all about him
history's american pickers is jam-packed
with colorful characters working their
hardest to get the best deals possible
on cars collectibles and other
high-priced items among the most beloved
in the show's rogues gallery is hobo
jack a nickname for antiquer jack sophia
the cheerful native of litchfield
illinois owns a lot of property in his
small rural town and tends to pan up the
most interesting things for host mike
wolfe to pick through and ultimately buy
from him sophia is skinny bearded
gray-haired and has a penchant for
breaking into tune and playing the
guitar thus far he's only appeared twice
on the show in season two's hobo jack
and season six is the return of hobo
jack but those two appearances won him a
lot of fans thanks to his steely skills
at the negotiating table it's perhaps
not surprising to learn that there's
much more than meets the eye when it
comes to hobo jack
american pickers has previously come
under fire for being a hair less than
fully authentic so it's perhaps not a
big shock to learn that jackson fear
currently lives a life that has little
in common with jojobas according to the
herald weekly in real life sapir
actually owns quite a bit of property on
which he's got a nice and comfortable
home and he is seen regularly bidding on
big ticket items and auctions all of my
life i've been collecting remnants of
the victorian era so you might not spy
the spry collector riding the rails but
you're likely to encounter him in places
such as the wayside antique mall and
other locales around his illinois
hometown while this revelation may
disappoint some hobo jack fans it's
worth noting that he's never been
anything less than 100 percent honest
about his point of origin video bob
whiteside who runs saphir's official
website is perfectly frank about the
multi-hyphenates collegiate background
and he speaks of his moneyed youth as
well a profile published in the
telegraph in 2015 also revealed that
saphir is the son of artist and sculptor
dorothy o young as sapir told the
telegraph my mother discouraged me from
becoming an artist because she said the
main way to make a living with art was
by teaching and she knew i was too shy
and introverted for that the article
also explained that sophia's parents
wouldn't fund his art school education
so he ended up paying his own way at the
washington university school of fine
arts saphir then reportedly spent years
traveling before buying property and
settling down in litchfield
hobo jack saphir isn't just a collector
he's also an author with multiple
published works and a musician with a cd
in circulation according to his official
website he's released three books to
date the latest of these is 2015's
amazing adventures of the [ __ ] prince
perth's official synopsis this book
contains very controversial opinions
about health animal rights human rights
government and injustice many of these
discussions are with a toad safire's
other works include the 2008 novel time
in a box which focuses on the journeys
of patches the dog and backwards the
railroad bum who becomes separated when
patches leaves their life to go soul
searching saphir also authored get a
horse a unique collection of early
automotive humor from turn of the
century magazines in 1989. additionally
saphir produced an album called the best
of backwoods hobo jack original songs by
an american picker saphir not only
writes and sings his own songs but he
also plays guitar harmonica and banjo
hobo jack apparently isn't saphir's
moniker of choice his unforgettable
nickname came from american pickers host
mike wolf in fact on his official
website zaphir bills himself as
backwoods jack forgoing the hobo
entirely in 2011 it was revealed that
sapir gained the name backwoods jack due
to the locale of his cabin safire's
collaborator bob whiteside explained in
a youtube video buzz potter and captain
dingo asked me about who jack really was
and a little about him i answered he
lives by himself on a winding road in
the backwoods they both smiled and said
that's it backwoods jack every hair of
his beard he was so interesting to look
at whiteside also claims that the
history channel came up with the hobo
jack nickname not wolf in a note on his
official facebook page saphir confirmed
whiteside's story and added that he'd
been performing his backwoods jack for
10 years at hobo festivals before
receiving it as his official hobo road
name at marquette iowa during a
gathering anyway you slice it backwoods
jack is a name that comes by honestly
according to the telegraph saphir lives
in a cabin with two dogs on his property
and the structure lacks running water or
electricity he does however use a
generator when he needs it
hobo jack sapir began collecting things
as a child he told traveling adventures
of a farm girl i can't explain why i
collect i remember around seven walking
home from school and looking for
treasure which i never found i just have
a treasure hunter mentality saphir's
favorite things to collect are classic
cars and car parts as he told the
telegraph i've owned probably 100 cars
in my life and i still have 30 of them
he also makes money restoring and
selling vehicles a hobby which
originally caused friends to suggest he
contacted the american pickers producers
american pickers has been dogged by
rumors that one of its cast members has
died on more than one occasion for
instance when frank fritz left the show
several websites circulated false rumors
that he'd passed away then in 2016 the
telegraph posted a bogus notice that
jack sapir had passed away to their
facebook page it's since been
immortalized in a screencap on saphir's
official website he responded in a
statement joking how many people get to
read their own obituary he also included
a modified quote from author mark twain
writing the report of my death was an
exaggeration happened to hobo jack
we died in the jungle
while sapir definitely isn't dead he
might be considering spending more time
smelling the roses according to the
telegraphs of fear expressed interest in
moving to san francisco where his
daughter lives but regardless of whether
he's living in the middle of the country
or on the west coast american pickers
fans will always root for their beloved
hobo
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite reality stars are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one